someday you guys might thank me for this
or not a decade may have passed since we
first saw Troy Bolton and Gabriella
Montez fall in love on the small screen
but High School Musical fans have yet to
forget about their story we're about to
reveal when even the biggest High School
Musical fans never realized about the
franchise so watch until the very end to
find out which important details might
have slipped right by you in today's
video we will be taking you behind the
scenes of the highly celebrated Disney
Channel franchise High School Musical
we'll be diving into the personal
experiences of some of our favorite
Disney cast members we're going to cover
everything from Zac Efron and Vanessa
Hudgens on set chemistry to a secret
feud we bet you never knew about let's
jump right in so we don't know if this
is funny weird or a mix of the two
but apparently things were pretty close
to what we saw on the screen when it
came to Ashley Tisdale and Lucas
Gribble's relationship entertainers are
so temperamental they played the
on-screen siblings Sharpay and Ryan
Evans in an interview back in 2008 Lucas
Grabeel went so far as to use the word
hate when describing how he felt about
his on-screen co-star Ashley they
initially met at the high school musical
auditions he said that he began to
dislike Ashley because she constantly
wanted to rehearse their lines together
until she felt that they were ready
while he preferred to work on his lines
alone since he felt more confident that
way during an interview with Billboard
magazine Lucas said he didn't want to
socialize much and wanted to work on his
own thing since he actually came
prepared
ouch not only did Lucas actually end up
rehearsing with her as many times as she
insisted on but she also gave him a ton
of notes and criticism in typical
Sharpay fashion today Ashley even admits
that she really was a lot like Sharpay
when she first auditioned for the Disney
Channel Original Movie the movie was a
large growing experience for the young
actress and everybody ended up getting
along just fine
in fact they eventually became one big
happy family we guess we can't really
complain about that one detail too much
since it did make for some on point
Sharpay drama another member of the
wildcat squad he was also a lot like her
on-screen character when she took on the
role of taylor mckessie is none other
than
Monique Coleman Monique was actually
very close to quitting acting all
together before landing a role in High
School Musical the ultimate reason she
did end up auditioning was that she
wanted to represent a smart and sweet
african-american character who her
nieces and God's sisters could relate to
at the time the only other prominent
african-american actress to appear on
the Disney Channel was Raven Symone from
Disney's that So Raven
this made Taylor's decision a majorly
awesome and brave one funny enough both
Ashley and Monique auditioned for the
roles of Gabriella as well but Monique
mentioned that she was not very
interested in landing the specific role
and felt totally out of place singing
and dancing for the part during the
audition process that worked out pretty
well for our girl since we just couldn't
imagine anyone else playing Taylor's
part one thing that the entire cast
always mentioned was just how close they
grew while filming the three movies they
also boasted about how much fun it was
to work together a fun fact for all of
you is that Ashley Tisdale and Monique
Coleman had actually already met on the
set of The Suite Life of Zack and Cody
so the girls were already pretty excited
to be working together again another
pretty funny story behind the High
School Musical audition process is that
they took place in a trailer with some
pretty thin walls so a lot of what was
going on during the audition process
could clearly be heard by everyone else
auditioning Lucas Grabeel who ended up
playing Ryan Evans mentioned that he
also auditioned for the role of Troy
Bolton but was completely shook after
hearing his co-star Drew Seeley seeing
in the audition room despite already
being a prominent Disney star drew
didn't end up landing the role of Troy
Bolton but that didn't mean that he
didn't get to play a pretty major role
in the movie franchise not only did he
get to sing all the tracks in the first
High School Musical movie but he also
replaced Zac Efron on tour when he was
too busy filming for hairspray drew also
wrote the lyrics behind the catchy song
gets ahead in the game and later went on
to star in another cinderella story
featuring the prominent Disney celeb
Selena Gomez Disney was a pretty
tight-knit celebrity community back in
the day which led to a whole lot of
movie crossovers and guest star features
Selena Gomez herself was actually meant
to guess star and one of the movies
particularly High School Musical 2 but
she apparently decided to reject the
offer to pursue more serious acting
Miley Cyrus on the other hand he was
already famous for her role as Hannah
Montana
maybe an iconic appearance at the end of
the second movie during the all-4-one
performance a little fun fact that not a
lot of people know is that there were
actually official online polls where the
fans got to vote for some pretty cool
things like which member of the Hannah
Montana cast would make a great
appearance and which desert Zeki should
give shar-pei in the first movie does
anyone remember what he ended up giving
her try letting us know in the comments
here's a little behind the scenes secret
you probably don't know about there is a
cast member who wore a t-shirt with the
words I love waffles sewn across it in
the first movie can you guys guess who
it is
well if you guessed Corbin Bleu then
you're totally right after noticing the
t-shirt in a wardrobe fitting Corbin
decided that iconic t-shirts would be a
staple in his character Chad's wardrobe
Corbin continued to trends by creating
his very own t-shirts all of which had
funny catchphrases and sayings on them
so what happened to all these unique
t-shirts
well Corbin still holding on to them
sadly they're being stored and not used
but still we're happy to know that
Corbin is holding on to some of his high
school musical memorabilia to end this
video on a sweet note we think it is
definitely worth mentioning that the
director of the franchise Kimmy Ortega
actually had a special yawning jar on
set which he used in a pretty funny way
every time a cast member yond on set
they were made to put money into this
jar this money would later be donated to
a charity of their choosing during the
Christmas season this was a great way
for the entire cast to stay motivated it
also ensured that the cast's on-screen
energy was spot-on
we absolutely loved the High School
Musical movies and we have to admit
Sharpay was our favorite character let
us know who your favorite character was
in the comments section below
and that's a wrap thanks for watching
the things be sure to give this video a
big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe for the latest Disney Channel
news we'll catch you next time
[Music]